thank you nate let's take things outside
and have an adventure there are multiple
places where you can do that here in
nevada
including a desert ranch experience
check it out
here at camel safari we have 34 camels
including dromedary the one hump and
bactrian
the two hump three of our camels are
calves that were born
on the property here in 2020 in addition
to camels
we also have a two-toed sloth african
crested porcupine
six-banded armadillos woolly opossums
hedgehog alpacas and llama our facility
is open and safe we are located one hour
north of las vegas on a 176 acre
property right outside of
mesquite nevada we are offering our
family day glam
camp which is a five-hour experience on
the property packed with socially
distant fun
guests can book thursdays through sunday
and the adventure lasts from nine am
until two pm
the family day glam camp includes up
close animal encounters with our animal
ambassadors
animal education program lunch
battery and camel fiber crafts and
also when the guests come they have
access to a
private authentic mongolian gear which
are equipped with
power air conditioning fridge loaded
with
snacks and drinks and authentic
mongolian furnishings
the camels are starved for affection
they loved being able to get out and do
the rides
and because we cannot do the rides now
due to coven
they have not seen as many people as
they used to
and they know that when the people come
that the treats the extra treats do too
and so they are excited when they see
people pull up onto the property
[Music]
we are also open as a unique and
beautiful venue
we encourage businesses and the public
to
consider our facility as a safe outdoor
facility for corporate retreats
weddings bachelorette parties and more
of course what we are able to offer
is very largely dependent on
the governors and cdc's guidelines in
these unprecedented times
and of course we are following all
safety
coved protocols
and the pricing for our family day glam
camp is 189 dollars for two people
or groups of four for 329 dollars with
additional adults being 85 and children
35.
we are safe and open and if you guys
would like to come
out and meet some of our awesome camels
for our family day glam
camp you can go to camelsafari.com and
book through the website
[Music]
do you want the desert ranch experienced
by camel safari
yes give them a call at 800.836.40
you can also find them online desert
ranch experience dot com
las vegas now we'll be right back